it's not a place that people would
associate with rest and relaxation in
Hong Kong the pursuit of quiet can be
challenging whether by day or by night
[Music]
while some visitors may find the crowds
and noise intriguing the locals do not
always find them enjoyable
[Music]
if you want to eat something it's better
to book ahead otherwise you might end up
waiting for an hour so for a table it's
so crowded on the weekends that you
can't even walk properly shopping areas
like this are very full but you can find
some quieter places further out there
are plenty of undisturbed places in Hong
Kong but there are often remote some
Hong Kong s don't mind traveling a long
way to put the chaos of the city behind
them but even the countryside is getting
more and more crowded say hikers like
Ming Qing Wong happens because of the
media readers may be astonished to hear
of these beautiful places in Hong Kong
but they're not big enough to support a
lot of visitors so once a place gets
famous you'll almost certainly get
overrun by people and perhaps another
reason why people turn to the
countryside green urban areas are also
jam-packed now you may say Hong Kong
people can just stay at their homes
while this may be true for some many
have to share a tiny apartment with
other family members for them space is
limited and they can't relax even at
home is there an undisturbed and
accessible place for Hong Kong's busy
citizens to chill out here's an attempt
right in one of the city's busiest
districts
[Music]
silence is for sale in this cafe called
still house coffee tea or sometimes a
piece of cake these are the only items
that customers can order in exchange for
a moment of peace and quiet
Muchin owns still house the artist hopes
to space can give people's minds a break
yeah let me show you I'll do get on down
today then everyone needs a moment in
space to be alone
24/7 table if you interact with others
24/7 at some point you lose sight of
what you really want from life that one
has to actually pay for silence fair
enough
say some customers for them the cafe
gives them a unique experience not even
nature can provide I live in the suburbs
where it's already quite tranquil but
even so I can't relax there as much as
when I'm here it's a very special place
it seems unreal to be able to watch
quietly as people down in the streets
rush by
but the opposite of a hectic life
doesn't necessarily have to be silence
[Music]
music also provides a good escape on
lazy afternoon
[Music]
you
[Music]